this is eight news now live at five live
local now
it's okay the police are coming okay
okay
i just called
new audio a frantic parent trying to get
help for a school bus after her kids
didn't make it to their stop and now
that mother believes the driver was the
victim of an assault we thank you for
joining us here at five i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis ccsd
confirming a bus driver was assaulted
happened near tone upon vegas drive
yesterday another driver attacked on
boulder highway in russell that was on
wednesday madison kimbrough spoke to a
parent who called 9-1-1 as her kids
alerted her to a problem with their bus
in that area
it was a frightening experience for
destiny griffin as she was going to pick
up her kids on wednesday right at this
bus stop up here on boulder highway when
she received a call from her kids crying
in need of help
[Music]
destiny griffin arrives daily at 3 20
p.m to pick her kids up at the bus stop
but she says on wednesday there was a
delay from their school at josh stevens
elementary her motherly instincts kicked
in that something was wrong she called
her three sons and they told her their
bus was pulled over on the side of the
road and they couldn't get off griffin
drove to the location herself telling
her kids to talk to the bus driver tell
the bus driver that i'm on my way and
911 has been called and they're on their
way because at this point i didn't know
what was going on i didn't know all the
windows were closed
the bus was off
engine was off i did the timing they
were on that bus for about an hour
no ac once griffin arrived she was
eventually able to get her kids off the
bus when she asked what happened to the
adults around she could not get a clear
answer her kids said there was some type
of commotion on the bus
griffin then heard about the bus attacks
with one of the locations where she got
her kids now i gave the bus number to
ccsd to see if it matched if that was in
fact the bus where the attack happened
they couldn't release that information
they said it's still under investigation
reporting live in the southeast madison
kimbrough 8 news now
all right madison so just into our
newsroom the clark county school
district police department has
apparently made an arrest in one of the
assault cases with the bus driver
46-year-old otis tanner arrested on
charges of battery on a protected person
burglary assaulting a school employee
and additional charges that assault as
you heard there happened near tonopah
and vegas drives and now there are at
least two attacks investigators are
still working on the other one which
involves several adults we do want to
point out this arrest is not related to
the bus in madison's story however